it is a real pleasure
for me to be here once again and today
we're going to be talking about the
emergence of social mind and its
eruption in autism and this lecture is
going to be followed by at least two
lectures on social brain by by doctors
Palfrey and the parkland and so today is
all about the mind it's all about the
emergence of social engagement from very
early on in life and it's possible
derailment and autism spectrum disorders
so I'm ami Klin
and I direct the autism program here at
the Yale Child Study Center and the
theme of this lecture is something that
our labs have been really dedicated to
for the past at least 10 years
so just to recap a few of the things
that we said in a very very very first
lecture we are looking for a way of
describing objectifying and quantifying
the behavioral phenotype in autism we
talked about it and how heterogeneous it
is and unfortunately for those of us who
are engaged in in research on the causes
of autism that heterogeneous
presentation is really very challenging
elements of the condition and so we need
to find ways of data quantifying that
are defining and better tracing and
development the emergence of social mind
and in order to do that there are a few
things that I emphasize in our first
lecture first was dr. Seuss thing 1 and
thing 2
being that the autism spectrum disorders
are first and foremost a social disorder
which means that there are many
disabilities and many competences as
well that you identify individuals with
autism but whatever you go and whatever
is the method that you are using to
research it you find out that there is a
bit of a dichotomy there that's
individuals of autism a show relative
strengths and their competence but they
tend not to be in the social domain and
therefore we
a biased and we define autism as first
in foremost as a social disability
secondly autism is a condition of early
onset very likely in the preponderance
of evidence shows that whatever causes
autism and there are many many causes
for autism those things happen even
before the child is born but in in in
many ways the disorder is instantiated
in the first two years of life and to
our mind the vast majority of
individuals of autism could be
identified early on and secondly a
social functioning we don't we don't see
it as some kind of a higher-order form
of cognition many people turn to us and
say why do you study social development
this is so complicated this is so
complex there are so many other things
that you could study that are more
fundamental well social adaptation is
not that fundamental because not only
human beings but also other animals many
many species they have to survive and in
order for them to survive they need to
be able to find their conspecifics and
they need to identify the Predators and
so many different ways when we talk
about social functioning we're really
talking about an ancestral ability there
has been with many species even before
the emergence of humankind but we
inherited that to accept that now we are
in in a sort of in a nice environment
and some of the skills that we use many
many many many years ago to survive in
the wild are now skills that we use in
order to be socially competent so it is
in this way that we feel that autism is
really a foundational a condition
foundational in the sense that what
seems to be involved in leading to this
condition is something that is disrupted
it's something that is foundational to
our ability to engage with others and to
end to process other people's social
signals to communicate with others
develop
and so forth thirdly and another
principle that we have learned maybe the
hard way over the years is that when we
as as laboratories for research
conductor studies we tend to focus way
too much on the results and we believe
that once we get a result we we are
finished with our job in fact in this
field is even more important to focus on
the process because individuals of
autism they may actually get things
right but they may get things right in a
different way and those alternate
learning pathways are as important as
the way that they show their
difficulties in many different ways
people have been so much focused in
autism in in ways in which the system
breaks down and we are equally
interested in the way that the system
builds up in a way because people
because social engagement because social
relationships don't come naturally to
them it does not mean that they don't
learn they learn they learn to
compensate for that in those sorts of
ways and sometimes when you conduct a
very strict study or if you observe them
in a very structured environment those
compensatory mechanisms work just fine
but it's when you see them in the real
world for example in in high school
cafeteria when they need to arm to
spontaneously orient to whatever is most
relevant in that environment
that's when those those compensatory
mechanisms don't work very well because
social interaction is fast paced there
are many things happening at the same
time I need to integrate that
information very quickly and in many
different ways we do that intuitively
and effortlessly and those are the kinds
of things that individuals with autism
have difficulty with and if we really
want to understand something about the
way that they learn to cope with that or
to fail to cope with that we need to go
beyond the results we need to know what
are the learning processes underlying
their ways of being in the world and and
finally one thing that we have learned
over the years
is that an this world out there for this
purpose could be divided it could be
divided into the worlds of people and
the world of things and for many of you
that dichotomy is not there because the
world of people is such a predominant
influence on everything that you do what
you attend to what you're interested in
what you are obsessed with in many
different ways as I look around I am
scanning your faces and trying to get a
good sense of the extent to which I'm
saying something that makes sense and if
not I'm going to adjust so I am obsessed
with your mind I'm obsessed with the
mental states that you have your
judgments your your intentions and your
emotions and that's paramount in almost
everything I'm doing right now now in
contrast to that I have encountered I
haven't counted the number of light
fixtures in this room I haven't paid
that much attempt attention to the
patterns of the carpet or how many
chairs are around these are things and
so they are not very important for my
ability to be a successful lecturer
today and yet for many individuals with
autism those are the things that come
first to their mind they are not
obsessed with the minds of others they
are not obsessed to be judged they are
not obsessed in becoming the object of
somebody else's subjectivity they are
often much more concerned about things
in the world and that takes their mind
away from people so those were some of
the principles you know somebody can
call it biases that we bring into this
lecture that we bring into our laps now
what are the kinds of things that we
trying to study we are trying to study
skills social adaptive skills that are
very early emerging meaning that they
emerge in infancy if not in the first
days of life in human infants and some
of those skills are also present as I
said in many other species so a series
of studies that I'm going to talk about
today have to do this concept of
biological motion biological motion is
simply our movements of other living
beings which contrasts with movement
things now this is kind of an abstract
construct but it shouldn't be that way
it's actually quite concrete everything
that you do your facial expressions the
gaze direction your bodily gestures your
posture your gait all of those things
are forms of biological movement and lo
and behold are not only that newborn
human infants can can detect and also
oriented financially to those kinds of
movements we see that in other animals
we see that in monkeys we see that in
cats
we see that in dolphins we see that in
newly hatched chicks in fact that
particular skill seems to be involved in
the learning process called imprinting
which is the way that newly hatched
chicks get attracted to and eventually
become a touched to to they're kind of
specific like mom hen but it's not only
that it's not only important to find mom
chicken it's also important to find the
catch meaning that it's also important
to find a predator and on the basis of
that that particular preferential Rhian
tation - biological motion is a survival
mechanism and the past 25 years and
neuroscience have shown quite a bit
about that learning process using the
chicken as a laboratory organism we've
been using that with human infants the
other skill that we pay a lot of
attention to is the is eye fixation the
eyes are not only the window to the soul
the eyes are also the window to to
social neuroscience babies from the
first days of life they are capable of
detecting if somebody is looking
directly at them as somebody's not by
the time that there are a few weeks of
age they prefer to look at people's eyes
rather than any other part of the body
the reason being that a lot that has to
do with your intentions with your
emotions with whatever you are about to
do seems to be conveyed through the eyes
now that happens you know as as babies
fall in love if caregivers
caregivers fall in love with their
babies but as you know this is something
that is important through the lifespan
lovers look into each other's eyes all
the time and most people wouldn't do
that freely because if you look at
someone directly into the eye soon
enough you're gonna find out that that
person gets a joke and the joke is that
people immediately know that you are
thinking about that and so the eyes are
really one way of establishing a bridge
between two minds between two hearts
between two people who are living
independently and yet for that moment
there is a shared experience so the eyes
are important not the eyes are important
also from a neuroscience standpoint most
functions in the brain get potentiated
if if if the stimulus is looking
directly at you so it's one thing to for
example look at a person's face but if
that person is looking at you well the
social brain about which you're gonna
hear from doctors belfry and McPartland
that signal gets potentiated it gets
potentiated not only in in other lessons
in adults it gets potentiated very early
on in in infants and so um the eyes are
the eyes habit as it were any it doesn't
happen only between humans it happens in
other species as well for example in
monkeys now adult monkeys are not going
to be looking in each other's eyes
unless you are the dominant monkey
because it's immediately immediately
conveys the sense of social status and
and it can be very threatening
if one monkey looks at the other so the
one that is the less dominant is going
to look at the other for a split second
and immediately look away and yet if you
look very carefully in the wild the way
that mom's meaning mom monkeys and baby
monkeys how they interact so there you
have this complete joint on mutual gaze
going on and that mutual gaze is really
critical because he implies that
the attachment has been has been formed
and that mom is now taking care of that
baby not baby much so this is not
something that is is is a feature of
human beings is that is a feature of
other species as well and in fact in a
funny sort of a way you can see our
bodies our brains and our anatomy in
general as kind of monuments to
successful adaptations what do I mean by
that the eyes are important so Nature
had a way of creating a big contrast
right here in my face that is going to
make possible for that little baby to
find the eyes and that's in the form of
the sclera in my eyes so the area of
greatest contrast in my face is that
between the sclera the white and the
middle of my of my eye and interesting
enough the more the species require the
attention of the caregiver the more
contrast you have there so as you go
down for example to two primates the
sclera is not so white it's not so clear
and as you go to other animals like my
chinchilla at home
well my chinchilla does not have sclera
which means that whatever caregiving
took place in the early life of my
chinchilla was not something that
appeared to be mediated or require the
immediate orientation of the baby
chinchilla to the mother chinchillas
dies so those things are just built in
this is very very foundational and
remember once again when we talk about
social functioning we're really talking
about adaptive functioning we're talking
about survival the kinds of things that
Darwin spent a lot a lot of time
thinking about so those are two of the
constructs that I'll be focusing on
today now those things have been looked
into from many different perspectives
and and just to sort of bring about one
of them which is probably the area of
greatest excitement in our field in the
past couple of years we have had many
many discoveries in genetics so now we
have a whole assortment not only of
genes but of genetic processes they have
found to be implicated and maybe
causative of autism there are many of
those and so um we feel that we are
closer and closer to finding out ways in
which we can maybe maybe target those
particular genes somehow and and and
ameliorate the condition for many of our
children and families well as it happens
it's not only the complexity but it's
also the gap that exists between the
discovery of genes and how that in that
house somehow affects our understanding
of the condition itself that is there
that gap is huge
genes tend to called for for proteins
not for behavior and so it is still
quite a bit of time before we can go
from from a gene to - to a protein - to
morphology of the of the nervous system
to brain information to circuitries and
to those kinds of things that are going
to lead us to a better cognitive science
of autism spectrum disorders having said
that that gap is huge and somehow we
have to narrow it from both ends and one
of the things that we've been trying to
focus on is is maybe trying to help our
and all of our colleagues in genetics in
neurobiology coming up with behavioral
assays that are going to be in a way
targeted in animal modeling or in our
understanding of gene function the
notion here is that autism is extremely
variable we have to find something that
is going to capture that disability and
will be a more proximal point to the
level of causation the things such as
dean is such as genes and
neurobiological processor tend to tend
to upgrade and and there is great
genetics already of social functioning
but we haven't capitalized on that quite
as yet in the same way the notion that
we're trying to to to to propose here is
that if we focus on those social
adaptive skills we go back in time and
we're talking about ancestral skills
there have been jerry-built into
functions and nature does not like to
sort of throw away great solutions for
Biological problems and so many
different ways we we we retained those
solutions but we Jaret build this new
system and now they are serving other
functions including the function of
being socially nice when you interact
with others or navigating the demands of
everyday life so I wanted to mention
that so on on this basis what I have to
tell you and and what our labs have been
focusing on are some very concrete goals
the first one is that we want to
objectify we want to quantify risk for
autism in the first years of life the
reason being that we need to be able to
detect risk for this condition as early
as possible because in so doing we can
capitalize on your plasticity early on
in life and maybe we can intervene we
can put in place treatments that are
going to optimize a child's outcome now
look at the kind of task that we are
facing with if we just think about some
of our neighboring states over 3,000
children are going to be identified as
having an autism spectrum disorder this
coming year so this is going to create
such an enormous pressure over the
entire system over the educational
system over all of the systems of
support we ought to be able to identify
those children early so that we can not
only alleviate maybe the condition we
can optimize these children's outcome I
think that all of us even though the
data are not there quite yet have
experienced in the past ten years that
early intervention really has made a
tremendous difference in the field and
we are seeing many more children doing
much better than ever before in order
for us to do that we need to be able to
detect these children even even early on
and one of the issues also that that
that give us the impetus to do this kind
of work is that there are tremendous
disparities in in our
sighs it in many different ways the
diagnosis of autism is made by tertiary
centers like ours and we are here
waiting for parents to seek us and yes
there are many parents out there there
are too too much in the pressure because
of their lives these are families from
disadvantaged backgrounds in minorities
that are not reaching service centers
like ours and so their children are not
identified or identified many many many
years afterwards and by then we have
less flexibility or malleability to deal
with and therefore it's more difficult
not impossible by no means but more
difficult to bring to bear on those
children the whole brunt of what we know
about early intervention in this field
by having something that is objectified
in quantified not unlike a tool you know
a tool that is used in investigative
medicine or in clinical medicine for the
diagnosis of specific medical issues we
need something that is going to be
playing the same role we need something
that is going to allow us to conduct
Universal screening of infants so that
we can identify those who are at risk
and empower the families to seek
resources to learn about the condition
and to develop a relationship with those
who are going to open the door to
clinical services now everybody seems to
know that and the American Academy of
Pediatrics have made that universal
recommendation for screening to happen
at least at the age of 18 and 24 months
but the field is still have been slow in
in in taking that up and one of the
reasons being that one some people feel
that we still don't know enough and
therefore why should we aren't parents
and secondly we don't have as yet the
methods that would allow us to identify
children in a way that is is as
objectified as a medical test should be
and so we still have not implemented
that recommendation very effectively we
need something that is going to be high
throughput meaning that we can see many
many made many children and and conduct
the
of clinical studies that are going to
detect the children who should be seen
again for clinical follow-up and
interesting I think that interestingly
the technologies are available out there
we are trying to research them but from
but our translational effort is yet from
the lab to the bedside in our situation
from our lab to the community at large
is still is still slow and yet I can
promise you that within the next 2-3
years we will have those methods we will
be able to identify risk for autism in
the first year of life and then we are
going to be faced with probably the
greatest biological challenge of our
time which is and now that we can
identify them what are the treatments
that actually make a difference and
treatments research has been slow in
coming
there is great stuff out there but we
still know too little about effective
treatments for very young children with
autism spectrum disorders so that was
the first one to identify risk early on
and the second one is the quantification
would be hero phenotype very briefly
because already mentioned that before
everybody who's a neurobiologist out
there or a geneticist feels baffled by
the phenotypic heterogeneity the
variability of this condition the fact
that individuals with autism they can
range from those with with IQs and
they're profoundly intellectually
disabled range all the way to gifted
those who don't talk at all those who
talk too much those who are
extraordinarily socially isolated and
those who can stop but coming to you and
asking you sometimes interpretive
questions now for somebody who worked at
that level of genetics and of
neurobiology that's too much
heterogeneity there is a need for
something that is going to be more
homogeneous some is something that is
going to bring a group together that we
can make sense off and the problem is
there are clinical instruments even
though they are very good at making the
diagnosis separating individuals if
autism spectrum disorders from those
without as I just told you there is
still too much variability we ought to
be able to come up with something that
is going to mediate between say a gene
finding in the Phoenix
and people like to call this a mediating
phenotype or an endo phenotype something
that captures the condition but it
captures it at a different level a
mediating level of complexity something
that is more proximal to birth because
that's more proximal to to gene
expression we doubt the very
complicating effects of things such as
learning and compensatory mechanisms and
environmental exposure in general and
and also something that is is going to
bring all of those different behavior
expressions into something that
cognitive scientists could actually
measure quantifiably and then use it for
the purpose of separating groups of
people and those groups would be more
homogeneous those were the biases that I
needed to share with you before I start
talking so that you know why I'm saying
what I'm saying that autism spectrum
disorders are first and foremost a
disorder of social interaction that
distance a vastly heterogeneous group of
people out there and in any any
principle that we use or methodology or
finding needs to somehow to be able to
capture that I mentioned to you before
autism is not a syndrome of intellectual
disabilities is not a symptom of mental
retardation and there are many very very
you know very simple genetic syndromes
out there they are single gene decisions
well many of them if not most in our
field are associated almost inevitably
with intellectual disabilities not so
this one because about 40 percent of
individuals with autism actually do not
have intellectual disabilities when I
start talking about social development
last time I mentioned to you that from
the first days of life babies orient to
others they prefer to listen to human
sounds than any other sounds in the
environments they prefer to listen to
speech sounds and they like to find the
source of the
Sam in the last trimester of gestation
they've been busily learning the voice
of their moms and and there is a very
good feeling about mom and security and
so when they are born they come here and
they want to find the source of that
voice and then they found that hugely
contrast the feature of the face called
the eyes they orient toward the
caregiver the caregiver oriented word
the baby and it's out of this mutually
reinforcing choreography that everything
that I have to tell you today seems to
advantage and so um I gave you that kind
of background last time it is still the
background for today our lab has also
tried to avoid researching things that
were abstracted from the world out there
and made simple why is that it is the
case that individuals of autism in
unstructured situations in naturalistic
situations that's when the disability is
greatest so we made a decision very
early on that in order to try to
capitalize on those disabilities and to
make sure that one don't that we don't
research something that is irrelevant we
would embrace the complexity of
something like that a scene from a
cafeteria in which the individual walks
in there and needs to figure out that
some things are more important than
others that some things happen together
that some things actually tend to convey
to you a sense of the context the
context of what is happening there is a
difference between everybody is eating
very nicely or there is a riot and
talking about two different contexts
well by figuring that figuring that out
very very quickly my behavior in that
situation is going to be more adaptive
or more relevant in our field
unfortunately individuals of autism may
walk into a setting like that without
figuring it out that context at all and
so that behavior not only that may be
inappropriate it may actually lead
some victimization they may not figure
it out for example that everybody is in
fact mocking them or people are setting
up situations so that they will look
like they were stupid and because they
are unable to bring all of those salient
pieces of information together and
attribute intentionality to others they
are extraordinarily vulnerable they are
vulnerable in their schools they are
learning and they are vulnerable in any
in any naturalistic environment so we
wanted to understand that
so we embrace that the problem is of
course that once you embrace that then
what you need to do is to work on your
measures okay and today I'm going to
show you only a few of our measures the
best measures I think we're going to
show you next time around because
they're not published yet so here we go
you remember that slide I presented I
believe in our very first lecture this
is a very very concrete and simplified
model for some individuals at the top of
that line the most important relevant
thing when they are born is the other
person and through this I curated
processes they end up becoming experts
experts on that person they sometimes
also replace that person with with a
transitional object and now they can
interact not only with supportive adults
but the peers they fall in love and and
on and off they go on becoming expert
some people now for some of our children
others are not the most salient thing in
the environment and they become very
focused on things and they keep on
learning
unfortunately keep on learning about
things ever more complex things but
things nevertheless and that's an
important thing for us to keep in mind
what do I mean by that because so many
wonderful adolescents and adults that we
have seen over the years with autism
spectrum disorders whose intellectual
prowess is unfortunately not match
by their ability to understand
themselves and others those individuals
use whatever skills they have and some
of them have formidable strengths to try
and make sense of things that for you
are quite effortless so um this very
very bright adolescent was very
interested in algebraic equations he
knew everything about how to break
equations he could solve the most
complicated he created his own but he
was very puzzled by the emotions of
others and so um what did he do he was
quite depressed and so he used a skill
and he would attach a ladder to other
people's emotions create those very
elaborate algebraic equations only to
try and solve them in order to gain more
insight into other people's feelings so
needless to say that was not a relevant
strategy but there was something that he
was not necessarily aware of and so he
would engage in things of this nature
and of course the worry would be that
one day one morning he would wake up and
he would have solved one of his
convoluted algebraic equations coming up
with a with a solution such as this and
then he'll be in danger because at the
time he was depressed he really wanted a
girlfriend really very much and so um
the worry was that he would find out
that he would never have a girlfriend
through one of his equations and then of
course he would need to be helped this
is another little piece of concrete
evidence of why we do what we do and
years ago we got a little bit frustrated
by the fact that investigators out there
who conduct studies with very high
functioning individuals about his
inspector disorders those individuals
were cognitively intact that those
individuals did not want to include
measures of adaptive functioning in
their protocols you had a lecture on on
assessment last week correct so you're
heard
I imagine quite a bit about the violent
ugly behavior skills which is something
that you measure what street smarts our
ability to navigate the demands of
everyday life our ability to fend for
ourselves not our cognitive power but
our ability to translate cognitive power
into real-life skills
that's what adaptive functioning is and
so um we have to show to our colleagues
that we had to include that in those
protocols okay and so um in a in a
collaboration with with our colleagues
from from University of Michigan we had
our two samples very large samples of
school-age children with autism spectrum
disorders and those were aged 8 to 18
and that this wasn't purpose because we
wanted to focus on school-aged children
and those individuals are verbal skills
were in fact higher than about 55% of
the population their age very
high-functioning and yet their street
smarts or what it comes there as
socialization skills as measures to the
violent was higher than 0.1% of the
population their age and their age
equivalent scores was you know close to
the four year range now that does not
mean that those individuals are like
children they're not they have big
bodies they have hormones they have
needs they have understanding of things
that go sometimes beyond yours and mine
in some areas but what that means is
that if we drop them in a bad part of
our beautiful town they will survive for
as long as a very young child so this is
what it means it means that once again
the contrast between their cognitive ex
their explicit their verbally mediated
skills and death thing that we're
talking about today which is social
survival which is knowing how to fend
for oneself in the real world now and I
also showed this to you last time but
once again just to know that we're
talking about the same thing
you remember that
classical cartoon was created by Fritz
Heider and Marian Simha when very young
children in fact when they look at that
cartoon they immediately think people
okay now this is the 38 year old adult
with autism a very bright adult he
doesn't have one graduate degree he has
two graduate degrees and else he was I'm
watching that cartoon this is what he
said starts when a small working lateral
triangle breaks out of a square a small
sphere circle appears and slides down
the broken rectangle the triangles were
either equilateral isosceles later the
small I think I just this triangle and
sphere bounce around each other maybe
because of the magnetic field so he
failed to see the social significance of
that social animation and was focused on
geometric shapes and on physics okay and
so one would say oh gee the reason why
he couldn't do that is because he
doesn't understand anything so here is
another animation that we that we
created and this animation doesn't tell
a social story it tells a physical story
and when I created that I thought gee
you know I'm having problems here
because some of our research assistants
were not necessarily figuring that out a
spouse was not figuring that out so I
thought this cannot be a control that is
too difficult are you seeing did you see
what that is
sorry he hearts back to my 60s and 70s
passion for the lunar program well there
you go there's a rocket
there's a lunar model module there's all
those kinds of wonderful things
happening there anyway I thought that I
was going to thrown out that to throw
away that that animation because people
are not figuring that out he was not a
control for the other animation until
some of my friends with autism begin to
watch that cartoon and here is what the
same gentleman said the rocket is being
launched and is in preliminary orbit
around the earth winding around the moon
of the appropriate distance so the de
satellite can be released the satellite
was launched from the rocket and
actually landed on the moon the
satellite was actually more like a lunar
module he got it he really got it in
fact this was the very best narrative I
got so um in many different ways
remember that I cottony between the
worlds of people in the world of things
he could not figure out a very simple
social animation and yet he could figure
out a very complex physical animation so
this is not a condition marked by
intellectual disabilities arm invariably
in many different ways four digits for
the genetics is out there it's important
for them to keep in mind that this is
not simply a syndrome of mental
retardation because we see that the
world of the world of of geometric
shapes and physics is very different
from the world of people and people seem
to somehow to effortlessly attribute
things that are most salient to them
once you know on the physics domain and
the other one on the social domain okay
moving on um you heard me say before
that looking at means thinking about and
so we have over the years tried to stand
right behind the eyes of individuals
with autism trying to see what in the
world that they see how are they making
out this world out there what kind of
images are coming through their minds
and what
of images are are being fed downstream
into the brains so that they are
recreating a constructs of the world
well um here is one situation and I
believe that I showed you this in my
first in my first lecture but this is
the starting point so it just repeated
you remember that the white cross here
it tells you exactly where a typical
adult is looking at exactly when
watching that scene from Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf and the black cross tells
you where the adult of autism is is
looking at on that scene so here's what
they do so one you appreciate how fast
that scene is and now in slow motion
well indeed so what happened there is
that the typical individual goes
straight into that man's eyes and the
viewer of autism goes alongside the eyes
is going to rest on the person's mouth
well the problem of course is that so
much of that young man's emotions are
conveyed through the eyes if in that
split-second you ignore it obviously you
fail to see something that was critical
for understanding the context of that
situation well here is another situation
as it happened this typical adult is
watching those two people engaged in
this very emotional interaction and and
he is going back and forth between those
eyes because once again those eyes are
telling you what is happening in those
two individuals minds and hearts and
here is the individual with autism going
between mouth and mouth and mouth and
mouth if you can see that cross because
he is almost entirely dependent on the
language that they are using
and and so his understanding of the
world is mediated through language the
problem of course is that people say
things that they don't mean they mean
things that they don't say and our folks
are overly literal they take language as
gospel and of course most of the time
people are using language in a different
way and if we don't understand that
language is contextualized by people's
facial expressions and by people's
bodily gestures and by people's
inflection of voice and the also the
behavior of others then of course we are
in trouble
and how subtle is this phenomenon not
very subtle in this situation there is a
very passionate kiss going on at the
foreground and that and that adult with
autism is actually paying attention to
something that is happening in the
background he is looking at the light
switch next door
well when we are when we try to get
those kinds of data and see how they
capture people's social disability this
is what we found out that the more
individuals with with autism look at
objects in those scenes the more
disabled they were and that's measured
in terms of their socialization skills
the violence of the behavior skills and
here the more they look at objects the
more disabled they were and the y-axis
here is from a standardized instrument
ei does the autism diagnostic
observation schedule so in many
different way what this is telling you
is that the Martel's folks were paying
attention to objects the last day our
understanding about the world and so of
course they are less able and they are
more disabled and here's something that
really puzzled us it puzzled us because
we thought that the converse would be
the more those individuals look at eyes
right um the more able and less disabled
they would be with those adults that
wasn't the case there is no correlation
which basically indicated to us that for
those individuals at that age meaning
when they are late adolescents and
adults they don't seem to
very much the language of the eyes and
even looking at them is not necessarily
telling something that is a particularly
relevance and it's not it does not have
much utility and their ability to fend
for themselves in the real world and in
fact when when when people tell me oh I
read those studies that you were that
you were doing years ago and and so I
thought that a very wonderful treatment
for individuals with autism would be to
make you know making them look at you
force them to look at you
and then you know what you end up with
you end up with something like this and
that means that I am looking at you but
so intently that you might think that
I'm staring at you but staring at
someone it's just the other side of not
looking it's just the other side of the
coin either way I'm not sensitive to the
value of case itself is not a mutual
case and so you know looking at not
looking at it's exactly the same thing
and it's amazing when we are having a
natural conversation with others we
don't stare at people all the time
we tend to look up and back again and we
try to do that naturally we only can
find ourselves unable to do that where
when we are a little bit anxious when
somebody tells you that he or she is
interviewing you for saying a fellowship
right in our program and we tell them
and one thing that we like to study is
actual mutual gaze when it comes to that
situation then of course what happens is
that you become oh sure they look and
look up it becomes a natural but
otherwise this happens very now this is
something that really caught us by
surprise um
why because what this means here is that
the more people look at mouths they're
more socially able they were and here
the more they look at mouths the last
disabled they were that's what those two
curves tell you and why is that well
it's so because those individuals who
have learned to try and understand the
others through language at least they
are playing the game
they may be they may be getting right
sometimes they often get it wrong but at
least they are playing this game if they
are looking at objects well then they
are not even playing the gaming they're
more disabled but in many different ways
what we are finding out here is that we
have an unusual result that is that that
is unveiling what is truly a
compensatory still trying to learn about
others through language explicit
language which has its problems the more
naturalistic the more problems you're
going to have I mean if I have that
individual sort of meet his peers who
are really trying to mistreat him well
he's gonna get in wrong most of the time
because they are saying things that they
don't mean however if they come to talk
to a very supportive clinician on a
one-to-one days as well this is going to
work just fine and that's the reason why
we need naturalistic situations because
that's when those kinds of compounds or
mechanisms break down okay now on there
is more to what we're trying to do
because in social interaction you know
things are happening it's usually not
two people there are several people and
actually by looking at another person
that's the way you get the context of
the behavior of another so in this
situation here what you're seeing is
hopefully is what you're seeing here is
a typical adult with autism actually an
adult with autism watching the the woman
in the man flat and looked at her hand
is on his knee she's flirting and he was
only focused on their mouth and now this
is a typical viewer and the person not
only that he goes back and forth between
people in check if that hand on the knee
is still there but that viewer is
constantly that viewer is constantly
checking the man in the background and
the man in the background happens to be
the yarn
woman's husband and so if you go and
watch what is the end result of that
particular sequence what you see is that
the typical the typical viewer is going
back and forth and back and forth
between the three people who form that
social triangle whereas the individual
if autism is focused is focusing on what
they say maybe some of the objects and
parts of people so it gives you a sense
of the picture that the eyes are tracing
or leaving behind that in many different
ways reviews what's going on in the
minds of people now this is another
scene from that same movie and the young
man here is is basically looking at that
picture in the background and is
pointing to it and he's trying to make
conversation and this is what happens
with the typical viewer the adult and
the viewer with autism also an adult
what happens with the typical adult is
that he hears the question which is who
made that painting he goes and follows
the pointing gesture scrutinizes the
picture and comes back here to this
gentleman to get the answer now this is
what the adult Eve autism did he heard
the question he knew that they were
talking about that picture but he
basically fails to see that pointing
gesture and he's looking which picture
which picture which picture which
picture which picture so in many
different ways he was failing to detect
a signal that it's something that that
typically-developing
toddlers do very effortlessly in fact as
we talked about before is one of the
things that make possible for us to
share experiences this is called joint
attention now this is another situation
in this situation what you see is that
the young man is trying to impress his
house and in that movie if you remember
I'm not sure if you ever seen this movie
it's called Who's Afraid of Virginia
Woolf is it it was an Oscar back in
nineteen
67 which actually happened you know you
believe that this is a for those of your
generation you might believe that the
the 60s did not happen they did and
there was a movie there cold I was
afraid of Virginia Woolf and and those
those two young people they are visiting
an older couple in this typical New
England College and the young man is
trying to invest so he is beginning to
say something very smart
to them right here in the first picture
and then his wife interrupts him as
wives often do and and she starts
talking you see she goes on talking now
the whole idea about that scene is that
the young man is getting embarrassed and
is getting embarrassed by his wife so
what does the typical viewer do goes
from this man now even before she begins
to talk he is already looking at the the
woman now he's looking back at the man
and he is noticing that he's embarrassed
and he goes back and forth and back and
forth got it in many different ways if
you want to get a sense of that
situation you need to look at both
people back and forth so that you get at
the intervention on the part of the lady
and also the reaction on the part of the
man and even though he was not talking
his facial expressions really were key
to understanding the situation what does
the adult Eve autism do well um here he
is the young man is talking he is still
paying attention to the young man's
mouth as he is talking and now the young
woman began to talk and so moves to what
you're saying
looking at her mouth and stays with her
throughout because she is talking all
the time so he totally ignore the
reactions of the husband which basically
means that he totally missed the meaning
of that particular situation
okay now is that because that man that V
where of autism is unable to follow
quick choose in the environment is that
that basically he's not getting anything
well not quite this was a very
emotionally charged moment in Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf
when Richard Burton is up to here with
his wife and so he decides that he's
going to go in this cabinet and is going
to reach for the top shelf and he's
going to get what turns out to be a
rifle okay and as soon as you know you
started managing imagining that rifle
you know what he's gonna try and do it
that rifle okay so that's a very
important aspect and the director of
this movie was absolutely wonderful
this it was Hitchcock like so what
happens is that as you see the frames
progressing in that particular scene
first it's on Richard Burton and then
there is a camera pan and the camera pan
is going towards the top shelf
now you remember Hitchcock do you know
who Hitchcock was I hope you do
okay great director horror movies worth
watching those again but one of the most
fundamental tricks in cinematography is
that when you are slowly going for your
camera pen something horrible is gonna
happen at the end
you remember cycle something horrible
had to be on the other end okay so
that's a physical cue it's not a social
cue so what you see here is that here is
the beginning of that scene and here is
where the typical adult is looking at
and here is you know the adult of autism
even though Richard Burton is not
talking he's still almost like waiting
for that mouth to say something and then
you see what happened with the other
sequences which is summarized in this
the viewer of autism gets to the shelf
before the typical viewer very quickly
and it fast now what happened with the
typical viewer he started you know
moving almost ended there in indeed I
action of the shelf but went back to
check Richard Burton's face is he really
doing that and then follows the signal
to go to the shelf so he gets that later
meaning after the individualism in that
scene my friend with autism outperformed
specifically dealt so it's not at all
a question that those individuals have
difficulty with motion or with fast
motion or that they have difficulty with
everything that i cought to me that we
talked about today is what seems to be
at the bottom of this now hopefully
you've got those examples those examples
are only benchmarks for you to remember
the way that individuals with autism
spectrum disorders are in adolescence
and adulthood so in order for us to try
and understand those things we have to
go back in time we have to go back in
developmental time and we ought to be
able to see how infants look at the
world and what are the things that they
make out of it so um as I showed you
we've been using those eye tracking base
methods because there is something about
the eye that reveals our innermost
motivations when we are walking around
walking around in the streets and we're
talking seeing people our eyes have a
way to focus on things that we wish they
didn't particularly for in public there
is something very very immediate very
automatic about finding what is most
relevant out there something that is
very important I was trying to be funny
a moment ago I cannot be explicit
because we are on video but I would like
you to have a little bit of an exercise
right now think about a situation that
you are in or maybe a colleague of yours
or somebody that you remember whose eyes
ended up on something that unfortunately
other people noticed and that something
is is something that they shouldn't be
looking at and that happened so quickly
that they they could not somehow
restrain themselves so that's the
immediacy that we are trying to
capitalize
okay that's why we're focusing on the
eyes and we do so in a very non-invasive
fashion nowadays our labs are such that
everything is done remotely so people
don't even need to be aware that their
eyes are being tracked or they don't
know they don't need to be aware of the
fact that we are measuring they stay
contain stating we measure their visual
fixations their visual scanning behavior
and so more and so on okay
all right um we talked a little bit
about very young children with autism
well these are the results of of some
social visual engagement experiences
that we conducted we have a little girl
a 15 month old little girl who came to
our attention because we had seen a
sibling who also had autism and at that
time his parents or her parents were
concerned about her she came to her
clinic she completed some experiments
and this is what happened we showed her
some we showed her some some kind of
experiences that would be very much like
the kinds of experiences that we
expected her to have every day so this
is a caregiver who is talking to her
okay and the cross tells you exactly
where that little girl was looking at
can you see
do you see what she's paying attention
to so she's being attention to the
woman's mouth and some objects okay did
I mention to you that from the first
days of life typically developing babies
they focus on the eyes they prefer to
focus on the eyes well this was not so
for this 50 month old little girl with
autism when we conducted this kind of
study with a larger number of toddlers
with autism we we compared them with two
other groups one of those groups is of
course a group of typically developing
toddlers because we want to know what
was normative in that situation those
are kind of novel experiments they
haven't been conducted at all and so we
needed to know what is the benchmark
where is the normative behavior but we
also compared with the third group of
developmentally delayed but not autistic
tothis and that group is really critical
for us to bring into our research
because if there are any findings in the
group with autism we can say that this
is not due to some kind of generalized
cognitive or language delay that this is
truly due to autism okay is that clear
to you thank you so what this graph
shows is this first these are the kinds
of stimuli that we use these were you
know caregivers approaching babies and
here what you have is the percent our
visual fixation from overall time a
fixation on four regions of interest you
have the eyes the mouth body and object
I only focus on eyes and mouth here but
what you see is that the toddlers if
autism spend much less time focused on
eyes relative to the two other groups
and they spend much more time looking at
the caregivers mouths relative to the
two other groups hey now if we show you
exactly the same data for eyes and mouth
there is something that should jump out
to you
this is the same the toddlers of autism
spend less time on eyes than they spent
on Laos but here there are two lines
it's a line for typical toddlers and for
developmentally delayed and for that
matter one-year development the delay
these were two-year-olds with one year
of developmental delay but not autistic
children and what do you see is that
those two lines are identical which
basically means that their cognitive
delay does not impact on their
performance at all and despite of their
delay their performance was very much
typical which means that this concert
that we're looking at is something so
basic and so fundamental that the
cognitive delays were not having an
impact on it okay and this was something
that encouraged us because now one of
our measures was predicting the way that
the toddler's vote ISM or in the real
world so they in many different ways the
less time they spent looking at the eyes
the more socially disabled they were the
more autistic they were so our little
measure was capturing something that
actually characterizes their disability
in the real world well how do we go
about saying those things looking at
means thinking about I would love and I
did want to do that at the time I wanted
to talk to that little 50 month old girl
leave autism and ask her tell me you're
not looking at people's eyes are you
thinking about people well unfortunately
this is not a question that I could ask
her so we have to come up with a way of
measuring that and the way that we
measured that is by basically creating
an animation and this animation has been
called in the literature biological
motion this is how we did
fold them into point flight displays the
children see a number of dots that moves
yes do you know that one it's a very
famous way
well what is happening there now this is
a test seen that before what are they
doing this is the only sound that is
going to come from you today so please
what is happening they are they are
fighting thank you
excellent so and this is very easy
people cannot but see those things as
people okay we created those animations
with real people real actress who are
reduced to those point line animations
okay all right so what is the paradigm
that we use well we use this paradigm we
showed that particular point light
animation up right over here and invert
it over here
why because the moment that you invert
those animations you lose the biological
motion nature of it not for you because
you're able to to somehow rotate that
but for young children as well as for
animals as well as the brain because the
brain will use different kind of neural
circuitry to process that particular
kind of inverted motion so what we
expect is that when our toddlers are
looking at those animations if they have
a template of human motion of human
interaction in their heads they're going
to look at the upright rather than in
the inverted because for all sorts of
reasons one of them being that adults
when they are approaching babies they
tend to approach upright correct okay
they do so and so that's one of the
reasons I would also like to point you
another manipulation that we did here
because it's going to be important for
something else that I'm going to show
you is that we didn't simply invert the
animation we also played it backwards
the reason why we played it backwards is
because otherwise the inverted in the
upright images would be mirror images of
one of each other correct and basically
we'll be forcing children to go back and
forth to compare them we didn't want
that to happen so we played the the
backward the inverted animation
backwards - okay
and so after we've done that we had a
little 50 month-old girl as well as to
comparison children to look at those
animations okay and this is what
happened the 15 month old with autism
was entirely random as you see here she
was almost 50/50 percent so she
basically went back and forth between
those two things neither of them was
more relevant than the other which tell
us that those uprights animations did
not seem to capture her social template
anywhere and this was not so for the two
comparison girls that we use one was the
50 month old little girl and one was a
nine month old little girl both of them
had a preference for the upright
animation okay but then there was an
exception and the exception was one of
our animations the patty cake animation
that you saw before when we looked at
that this is what happened you know that
15 month old if autism was almost
entirely on the upright side meaning she
got it totally okay and so my colleague
Warren Jones with whom all of those
studies have been sort of created and
and agonized over for the past 10 years
we sat down in my office and we looked
at those results that we thought we got
something wrong here maybe when we were
Colding we didn't get things right and
then we start checking everything and
everything was just fine and then we had
to ask ourselves the question what's
wrong with patty cake what's so special
about death animation relative to all of
the others that we use and some of the
others that we use are like feeding the
baby we're just approaching the baby and
you know very very typical kind of
infants directed speech and that one was
a different one and so we look it back
and see if you figure out what's
different about this animation what's so
special about that and I'll tell you all
animations had speech so speech was not
the difference here in fact on speech
provided a context to afford that social
context right but this animation and
only this animation has something
special
he had the clap and so we thought gee
clapping
physical physical contingency those
lights are hitting each other and they
are creating a sound that's a physical
contingency which is exactly different
from everything else that is happening
there which is of a social contingency
nature and so we look here what is
happening is that because you remember
in the inverted one we played it
backwards so now the clapping was
absolutely synchronous with those two
lights hitting each other and here on
the inverted it was no longer
synchronous because we played it
backwards and yet the sounds of course
go only for words so now pay attention
here and you see that the clapping is
this synchronous can you see
well if so we had an iPod Isis and
lipolysis was that the reason why she
was so much on the up right it was
because even though she was blind to the
social context of our social animations
remember those are things that babies do
I mean newborns are able to distinguish
that from other movements in the world
that even though she wasn't able to to
to attribute social social contents to
those animations here she was acutely
aware of a physical contingency not
social and that is the audiovisual
synchrony of Lights colliding and and
the and the sound and if so this is now
her data and we're which you will be
looking at you'll be looking exactly at
the clapping see if you can see where
she is looking at do you see the cross
right here so she was looking exactly at
that
she was looking exactly at that clapping
well she um
she showed us something that we thought
was actually quite quite interesting
random for all of the social animations
and then totally on the upright for a
physical contingency now in order for
you to pay attention to the physical
contingency you have to ignore the
social contingencies most people Jane
just look at those points light displays
and that's all they see
you'll be almost impossible for me to
ask people to spontaneously seek
something of a physical nature because
you have to reduce that to sounds and
lights okay so we followed up on with
another study and we use you know a
group of toddlers of autism who are
matched on nonverbal skills to a
typically developing group of toddlers
and matched on verbal skills or to a
group of two-year-olds who had
developmentally the developmental delays
cognitive delays but we're not at the
stick and here is what we got very much
like in the case study that I just
mentioned to you the table sieve autism
were random so they also could not
figure out the social animation and both
of the other groups the control groups
showed a preference for the app right
animations and lo and behold the same
thing applied to pattycake here
the toddlers with autism were also
showing a preference for pattycake and
the others continued to show a
preference but we thought for different
reasons the toddlers have autism because
of the physical contingency and the
other groups because they were still
matching on the basis of the social
nature of the operative nation okay that
was a nice hypothesis but how could we
possibly show it to be true and so um we
thought okay this is what we're going to
do pattycake was a kind of a blatant
example of course this is all unplaned
your
right this is you know if you don't want
to say that you're wrong you say it is
serendipitous so in a way it is
serendipitous we're figuring those
things out as he were you know a
posteriori but here we go
um this was a very blatant example of
physical synchrony and we thought that
when people talk there may be other
audio-visual synchronous simply because
when I'm talking with you and if I'm
cognitively fine
if I am to me negatively competent a lot
of what is going on in my body is also
going to be synchronous with my voice
why because if I want to stress
something I'm gonna stress with my body
and with my voice
do you understand that great because
this is important we thought that maybe
underline that random set of results
that we got the folks the two-year-olds
of autism we're still seeking those
physical contingencies okay and here is
an example look do you see of course if
you're watching this as you know as a
person you're you're not paying
attention to any synchronous between
lights and sounds but if I ask you to do
it you're gonna see that there are
synchronous like that most of us ignore
them entirely because of the social
nature this cartoon okay so in order for
us to figure out if underline those
kinds of those kinds of results for
details of autism that underlying the
randomness they were still seeking or
the visual synchrony this is what we did
we first of all we measured the change
in motion of those figures the upright
and then the inverted
and changing motion basically means
change in acceleration okay and here we
measured the change in sound in volume
and then what we did is that we try to
align those things and what those lines
are telling you is that on those it
dissolves you have a great yield of
audio-visual synchrony because you have
changing motion occurring exactly at the
time of changing sounds exactly at you
and this is from the pattycake lap and a
clip and so um you don't have many
things going on in terms of audio-visual
synchrony for the inverter okay and how
does that reflect itself in the real
world now you're going to see the the
the those Clips I'm going to show you
only one and what you're gonna see on
the right here is a heat map and this
heat map tells you that the very bright
sort of hot colors is when you have
maximum audio-visual synchrony and the
cold colors the Blues is when there
isn't any synchrony at all
now remember now you forget that those
things have any social characteristics
at all
it's only sounds and lights okay do you
see by watching this video you
immediately see that there is some
audio-visual synchrony happening here
too in spurious we didn't plan it to be
there way but this is important for us
because we could then measure how much
more audio-visual synchrony there was on
one side of the presentation relative to
the other do you gather let's do it
so this is one example for patty-cake
there is much more on the upright than
on the inverted but on this clip you
know is one of the Phoebe exercises
there it was more or less comparable
okay
good and then we also measure what the
children did from the standpoint of
their visual behavior for those
particular clips and so what you have
here is this
they are the x-axis tell you how much
more audio-visual sync rate there was on
the Opera on the upright presentation
relative to the university and on the
y-axis you have how much more the
children looked and the upright relative
to the inverted okay
and so we line them up the results and
what we could find out here is that 90%
of their visual preferences could be
accounted for on the basis of the amount
of audio-visual synchrony in the upright
relative to the inverted now even if we
remove patty-cake which was an extreme
case this was still happening and this
is what happening to the two other
groups they typically developing
toddlers entirely ignored what was going
on in terms of audio visual synchrony
our divisional sync revision behavior
had nothing to do with each other
because you're paying attention to the
social nature of the animations and the
same thing here for the non-autistic but
developmentally delayed groups okay
because we submitted this to a nice
Journal they said this is all very nice
and interesting and since all a
posteriori you need to create two
additional experiments you need to see a
brand new cohort which we did and we
came up with two additional experiments
to cover the gap that existed here in
terms of the amount of audio-visual
synchrony on the upright relative to the
inverted we created those two different
experiments we measure the visual
behavior for a new cohort and lo and
behold and we could predict very
accurately what they would do insofar as
visual preference is concerned okay no
what does that tell us remember what I
showed you before this is the way that
their 50 month old little girl was
watching a caregiver approach here she
was spending a lot of time looking at
the
his mouth so now it's my time to ask you
to wake up and to answer the question
why why do math well why the mouth
because in our face the mouth is the
site of greatest audio-visual synchrony
because lips are moving as we as it'll
speed sense now if so then you have to
ask yourself the question eh so you're
telling me that those children are
looking at mouths because they were
seeking audio-visual synchrony lights
and sounds remember now you can only do
that if you ignore the social nature of
those animations correct and so the
hypothesis that comes from those kinds
of results is that our little children
as they are watching caregivers approach
them then they may be reducing the faces
of those caregivers into a composite of
physical contingencies and if they are
doing so obviously they are not
intuitively and naturally oriented and
engage with the social nature of the
presentation which in real life is
basically that object out there that is
going to engage them in the mutually
reinforcing choreography from which a
lot in social mind and social brain
depends so so this is a kind of a
radical hypothesis I'll have to finish
here today in terms of present of
presenting to you some data but what I
can tell you is that we conducted the
next critical experiment which is if so
we could go back to the data that we had
of toddlers looking at caregivers we
would now use the methodology that we
created to measure the visual synchrony
and we would now be able to substantiate
or not the possibility that the reason
why our children are looking at the
caregivers Mouse is because they are
seeking all the visual synchrony well
that study was conducted and and the
results are here the results are such
that not only the audiovisual sinker
prediction could explain the fact that
the children were spending time looking
at the mouths of caregivers but we also
found out that even when they are
looking at eyes that also could be
predicted by the level of audio-visual
synchrony contained in the eye region
because as we are talking remember we
are moving around and we are making
facial expressions and some of those are
also synchronous we have the sounds we
make but if the audiovisual synchrony is
what is guiding my engagement to the
other
so obviously I'm missing something that
has a more immediate more automatic
appeal which is how we started today all
has to do is social survival right your
has to do with an adaptive reaction now
it does not mean at all that our
children are not establishing
relationships with others they are it
doesn't mean at all that they are not
making anything that they are failing to
make sense some sense of the world out
there it does not make them any
different than they were before but what
it does mean and we ought to be able to
capture that is that they are learning
about the social world in a very
different manner if they have somehow to
come up with a compensatory mechanism
because they've reduced the approaches
of others to a composite of physical
contingencies that it's clearly the case
that they need something out there to
mediate between them in the world and
here is that same that same little girl
watching another caregiver spending a
lot of time looking at that caregivers
mouth now all of this research is with
two-year-olds okay and needless to say
those skills preferential attention to
biological motion fixation on eyes I
mentioned to you our skills that your
borns are able to demonstrate to shows
you so we've been using those kinds of
techniques in our study of newborns and
this is Warren Jones
and you're gonna see this little girl
how she is enthralled by the image of a
caregiver
so we're conducting exactly the same
experiments and we're doing that from
the time that's children are born and we
are following siblings of children with
autism very intensively and very
comprehensively basically what we're
doing we are engaging them before they
are born and we're starting to see them
and we're starting to see them in the
first month of life in the second and
third and fourth and fifth and six
months and then every three months until
they are 24 months and we see the game
at 36 months to see what happened to
them and the whole idea is that we know
virtually nothing of the early
development of those skills in
individuals of autism and by following
this at-risk population these are
siblings which means that they are at a
greater genetic risk of also developing
autism some of them will and by
measuring those particular skills from
birth we will be able to identify the
very sort of early departures from those
normative benchmarks what we're trying
to do is to create growth charts not
unlike the growth charts that you see in
the pediatricians office except that
those growth charts that we are creating
at go our growth charts for for social
developments and by having a quantified
way of doing that we will be able to
identify a departure and by doing so
we'll be able to identify risk and then
intervene okay now why those things are
important to us remember that I
mentioned to you that autism is a highly
heterogeneous family of conditions
basically there is tremendous
variability and the phenotypic
heterogeneity really baffles all of us
including geneticists and near
biologists well there is another thing
baffling everybody is that genotypic
heterogeneity really equals you not
surpasses from the typical originating
there are a number of genes that have
already been identified which have which
are associative autism not only genes
but genetic processes
so um when Matt states I call it comes
here to talk about what do we know about
the genetics of autism he might give you
a review article that has two pages
we've all the finest today okay and all
of those things are etiologic meaning
that they are potential causes of autism
maybe in a very small number of cases
sometimes in one individual one family
only so there aren't going to be many
many causes okay and one of the real
sort of a puzzles that we've had a
puzzlement that we had to contend with
is this notion that yeah it is a
heterogeneous condition but myself as a
clinician as I walk into a play room or
into a clinical room to interview
somebody I can tell you that you know a
few years of experience I know that
person has autism in many different ways
it's probably the best the most
specifically diagnosed condition in
child psychiatry if you measure the
inter-rater reliability of experienced
clinicians it's fantastic so the
question that we've been asking
ourselves is not where is the
heterogeneity coming from but where is
the homogeneity coming from how come
despite genotypic heterogeneity Fannett
if ik has originated this is still some
kind of a unitary family of conditions
any in order to try and begin to address
that in a novel way we're looking at
development because it could be that a
range of causes are forced into this
unitary syndrome by means of development
meaning that human beings as well as are
the species they all undergo some kind
of universal process of adaptation or
socialization they all have to go
through that and you may have different
causes impacting on that but because a
very fundamental process is interrupted
that's what the disability is autism
cannot be traced back to a genie
autism could be viewed as the result of
not having those mechanisms and social
adaptation working properly and so
you're trying to make sense of the world
you're trying to adapt there and you're
developing those symptoms and if so then
development is critical and what we're
trying to do is to create those kinds of
growth charts and in order to do that we
hope to be able to better make sense or
some other data that is out there for
example there is a sense and I imagine
that either Kevin or Jamie are going to
be talking about that that's um there is
accelerated hack growth happening in the
infancy of some individuals of autism
well what does that mean we don't we
can't take data such as this and map on
to clinical profiles unless we have a
sense of what the clinical profile is in
many different ways we're looking at
this process of social engagement and
the different milestones that are reach
universally in all cultures and trying
to think about what might happen if say
that causative that causative factor was
impacting on the beginning of the
process right here or maybe here or
maybe here or maybe here
well our hypothesis is this if you
disrupt the process very early on the
cascade of events begin very early on
correct so it's much more likely that
that child is going to be more disabled
more severely affected if you saw many
hundreds of infants you will see the
difference between a baby died at the
age of one month and five months and
nine months and 12 months and 18 months
and 24 months it's the most rapid period
of neuro and behavior growth and so
maybe if that disruption whatever is the
cause it at six months you would have a
different cascade of events at a nine
months I live in many different ways
what we're trying to understand is the
severity of the disability on the basis
of where
that initial process was disrupted okay
and why because if we do so we might
make sense of where should we look for
the troubles
remember genes codes for proteins
proteins lead to brain to neural
circuitry right but do we know do we
have a scheduled maturation of our
brains because if causative factors are
having you know a one-to-one
correspondence or some form of a
clinical impact we ought to be able to
go back and see where in the maturation
of our brains lies some of our kids well
that's the story the main sort of point
that I want to convey to you is is this
in our field if we want to understand
the behavior of individuals of autism
later in their lives as as
schoolchildren
as adolescents and as adults we ought to
be able to go back in time and see what
they were like as little babies the
thing FinCEN toddlers because whatever
they were showing then was a natural way
of adjusting to the demands of that
particularly adaptive task because our
folks are very capable sometimes and
they can develop all those wonderful
ways of compensating for the disability
and sometimes when we conduct your
imaging studies with adolescents and
adults we are often frustrated because
you may have a finding but you don't
know if that finding is causative of
autism or is the result of having had
autism for many many many years so we
need somehow to have a clear sense of
development in order to know what comes
first and remember that there is
tremendous variability and the only way
that we might be able to understand this
tremendous challenge here is by breaking
that social complex set of behaviors
that they show later on into those very
early adaptive reactions
typically not only shown by human
infants but also by other species
because other species have been here for
a long time and they had to survive in
the wild - and those ancestral
mechanisms nature does like throwing
your way so what it does eat Gerry
builds new systems to perform new
functions okay well we have to thank
everybody who has been supporting those
kinds of studies the National Institute
of Mental Health the National Institute
of Health and Human Development the
National Science Foundation the Simons
Foundation Autism Speaks the Associates
of the young child Study Center and most
importantly the children and families to
have been participating in our studies
those studies have been going on some of
those studies for you know maybe nine
ten years
Warren Jones is actually the co-founder
the co-creator the co everything of
everything that I showed you today he's
not here he's getting married actually
he got married last Saturday and it's
lovely to put that on YouTube but he has
been he has been really a privilege to
work with for the past ten years but I
have many other colleagues as well who
have been contributing to those studies
Gordon Ramsay a whole set of wonderful
students some of them are are here and
also some other colleagues who are
listed here either because they've
commented on things that we've done of
because they've contributed to our
clinical constructs or to our clinical
work in general so thank you